- Very good.
Well, welcome to "Multicloud
security best practices."
I think we're best friends now.
- I think we just became best friends.
- This is Luis. I'm Geoff Sweet.
I'm a security specialist here at AWS.
I've been here about six years,
a little over six years,
and I have many loves in life,
but one of my very biggest loves is tacos.
- My name is Luis Pastor.
I'm in Geoff's team, as you can see.
I've been here for three and a half years.
And love is never a competition,
but if it was,
I love tacos more than Geoff.
And we're taking recommendations,
so at the end of this talk,
if you have a good recommendation
for a taco in town,
let us know.
We'll be over there.
- (chuckles) Yeah.
And because this is a silent session,
we won't get the chance to
do active question and answer
during the talk.
But, Luis and I will be
out back here afterwards.
So if something comes
up you want to ask us,
please come back.
We'd love to chat with you.
So our session today,
we're gonna talk about
some of the challenges
that goes on with multicloud,
security strategies specifically.
We're gonna talk about
some common challenges
like how and where to federate,
how to manage your data
protection and privacy,
how to gain some visibility
around what's going on in
your multicloud architecture,
what does it mean to scale your teams
or tools to help you in that endeavor,
and what are some next steps
and some resources that
are available to you.
I'm happy to tell you that none of us,
Luis and I are not here to
talk you out of multicloud,
but we're definitely here to help.
So, multicloud security strategy.
- So we love definitions.
So let's start with the definition.
So at AWS, we are defining
multicloud as an organization
that operates in two or more
cloud service providers, right?
That means you have IT
solutions or workloads
in two or more cloud service providers.
Is there anybody here that's
already operating in this way?
Yeah.
A lot of us already are there.
So we really wanna make sure
that you have the freedom
to operate wherever you can
do that more efficiently.
And like Geoff said, we're here to help.
If you're interested on
security, we have this talk.
There's other conversations
in the session going around
FinOps, observability,
developer experience,
and that we are going to
be the multicloud booth.
So come and say hi.
We'll also show you
how we created the picture in
the beginning, if you want.
No AI,
only Photoshop.
So,
many of you already multicloud,
so you already know.
Most organizations don't just
wake up one day and decide,
"I'm going to deploy in a
different cloud," right?
A lot of us have
different business drivers
that are gonna push us to go that way.
We have some examples here.
They're not all of the different
drivers that may push you,
but these are some of the
ones we see constantly
through our conversation
with our customers.
The first one is gonna be
mergers and acquisitions.
This is where your organization
acquires another one,
and then maybe you
operating in another cloud,
so now you're a multicloud organization.
Like if you operate a taco place
and you buy a quesadilla place,
now you're operating both, right?
So you have to understand
both considerations.
Differentiated capabilities.
Maybe you have a workload
that has specific business requirements
and then you are going
to deploy that workload
in another cloud that
better fit your needs.
So you're gonna become multicloud.
Regulatory requirements, right?
This is more to do with
security and compliance.
Think about things like data sovereignty.
Maybe you have to deploy in
one place that's a geo location
and that drives your
decision to go with one cloud
on another one.
And then, of course,
independent software vendors.
Maybe you start working with an ISV
and that ISV is operating another cloud.
Maybe your share of their
responsibility model,
your controls that you're
responsible for are lower
on that use case,
but you still have to understand
how they're addressing
your security concerns.
So I think the takeaway from this slide is
that it doesn't matter what the driver is,
the concern here is going
to be governed security
and compliance, right?
That's going to have to be extended
throughout your multicloud estate
so that you have the mechanisms in place
to protect the data that you're using,
the systems that you're using.
So we'll go through that journey now.
Let's talk about some of the questions
that you may want to ask yourself.
You may already be there,
but it's maybe a good thing
to start thinking through
some of these considerations
to understand the challenges
that you went through
and maybe come up.
And we have more than this,
so please talk to us after this talk.
We can have longer conversations.
But one of them is going to be,
how do your security operations
look like now, right?
Do you have a good understanding
of your current state?
Do you understand where your controls are
and how they are protecting
your data, your systems?
Do you have the capability to
extend those security controls
to a multicloud environment?
Here, we're talking more
about people and process.
So do you have the mechanisms in place
to extend those processes
to a multicloud environment?
Are you ready to move to another CSP
and expand your estate to a multicloud?
Another one is going to be,
who will own your security response
and monitoring capabilities, right?
A lot of organizations
have that distributed.
centralize those capabilities.
So what are you gonna do?
What's your decision gonna be
and what considerations are
gonna drive that decision?
This is true for other
security capabilities,
but in our opinion,
most important for security response,
because timing is gonna be of the essence
when you're responding to an event.
And then monitoring,
because visibility is going
to be so much more important
in a multicloud environment, right?
It's already important
when you have one cloud,
it's gonna be more important
when you have different clouds,
when you talk about two or three,
even more important, right?
Another question you may ask yourself is,
what tools do you already
have that are multicloud?
A lot of our customers focus on tooling,
and this is an important consideration,
but the good news here is
that a lot of the tools
that you may already be using,
they're already multicloud.
So you can start extending those.
And if you have expertise,
if your teams already
know how to use them,
how to deploy them,
it's a lot easier to deploy them
to a multicloud environment.
You get those benefits right away.
Another one of the
questions is going to be,
what are the divisions for?
Things like SecOp, AppSec,
governance, auditing, security.
So all those teams are going
to have to communicate,
coordinate,
and if they're doing it in one cloud,
it's gonna add a lot of complexity
to do it in two or three.
So how do you think through,
how do you best manage your teams
and the tools they need
to drive those security requirements
throughout the multicloud state?
And finally, but even
maybe most important,
how do you enforce data governance?
Do you know where your data lives now?
You have good data flows,
you have good diagramming that
tells you where your data is,
how it's being processed,
how it's being transmitted,
where is it stored.
Because it's going to get more complex
in a multicloud environment.
And you really want to
understand where your data lives
so that you can apply
those security mechanisms
where that sensitive data is,
so you can protect it, right?
So these are some of the
considerations and challenges.
Let's start addressing some of those.
And one of the things we recommend here is
start by using a multicloud
security framework, right?
Here, we have NIST CSF.
So a NIST cybersecurity
framework as an example.
It doesn't have to be this one.
Pick whatever fits your needs, right?
Whatever you may already be
using or even an integrated.
But what the point we're
driving here is going to be,
pick a high-level cloud-agnostic,
cloud-neutral framework
that can drive your
posture forward, right?
So focus on those outcomes,
not recommendation.
We'll talk more about what
that means in a little bit.
But the multicloud
security framework is going
to help you in a couple different ways.
So we talked about measurability, right?
It's gonna help you
understand where you're at,
and it's gonna use that
cloud neutral language
to evaluate your entire
estate across the clouds
to understand where you're going.
So when you have a good security baseline
that is comprised of those
cloud-agnostic controls,
it gives you something
you can plan for, budget,
and measure against.
The second thing it's gonna
provide you is the ability
to communicate more effectively
within the teams, right?
You have that cloud-agnostic framework
that you can use to communicate.
We need this requirement
or this control to be implemented
throughout our estate.
It really doesn't matter
how it's implemented,
it matters that it's implemented
and we know that it's in place,
and it's doing it effectively, right?
Technologies may change,
but the outcome should be the same.
So let's put it all together.
Security doesn't care where your data is
and it doesn't care where
your workloads live.
It really-
- I got an idea.
You know, our supersonic
drone taco delivery program,
my Uncle Elroy's got a cloud provider,
he runs a cloud provider.
- Really?
- Yeah, yeah, man, it's in his basement.
- Does he comply with all
the security frameworks?
- No.
- Then no, we cannot use that.
So here-
- Whatever.
- We really want a cloud service provider
that is adhering to a lot of
the compliance frameworks.
Once you have established
which one of those requirements
you wouldn't have to align to
from that compliance frameworks,
you can drive that operational excellence.
So again, you really
don't have to focus on
what are the specific mechanisms in place
to drive those controls,
but that the controls are in place
and are acting efficiently.
And so it's outcomes, not implementation.
- So outcomes versus
implementation is something
that we start to see customers
become challenged with
when their growth starts to
expand into other clouds.
Because we want to have policies
that define
and control objectives, right?
And we want our development teams
to turn around and be able to
implement those effectively.
And one of the challenges is that
if you are kind of a small,
not even a small company,
if you're a company that's just operating
on a single cloud provider,
or maybe you are a company migrating
into cloud from on-prem,
you might end up with security teams
that have defined security policies
that include implementation, right?
So here's a good example
of something like that.
We've told our development teams,
for data that is classified
as internal, right,
we want you to store it on S3
with some given KMS encryption policy.
And for our development teams
that are operating in AWS,
this makes perfect sense.
We can deploy it, it's easy.
But what happens to our teams
that need to take that security policy
and go to another cloud
provider like Azure or GCP?
We now have created confusion.
And in that confusion,
you're gonna begin
overwhelming security teams
because your development
teams are gonna consistently
keep coming back and going,
"Well, wait a minute, what do you mean?
Is this gonna be okay? Is this okay?"
So instead,
we want to look at security policies
that still achieve our
security outcomes, right?
Here, with just a few
small tweaks to the policy,
we've now said,
internal data, when stored in cloud,
must be stored in an object storage
with the following types
of encryption, right?
If you look back a few years ago,
Stephen Schmidt,
he spoke on the top 10 things
to be doing in your AWS.
One of the things he talked about was
implicit policies, right?
Policies that are easy to
follow and easy to understand.
And this is where we've come to.
So now we have a policy
that achieves our outcomes,
can be applied anywhere,
including on-prem.
And then out of that,
we can begin creating
implementation guidelines.
And in fact,
those implementation guidelines
might come out of those
very same development teams
who then say,
"Here's how we did it and we
were approved by security."
So let's talk about common challenges.
A lot of what goes into this list,
it comes out of Luis
and I, and other folks,
our conversations with customers.
If you have got a challenge
that is not on this list,
I would love to talk to you after this.
I'd love to hear your voice
and understand what you're up against.
But we grouped these into the categories
mapped to the CSF.
So in protect,
starts with identity management.
You've got a bunch of places
where your developers have been approved
to run their workloads.
How do you identify,
how do they get there?
How do they authenticate?
What is your authn, authz
mechanisms look like?
Again, in the protect category
is data security, right?
There's gonna be a lot of data.
How do we manage it?
In detect is continuous monitoring.
You now have a lot of architecture.
You need to have visibility
into what's going on around it.
And in the respond category
is incident (clears throat),
yes, incident management (chuckles).
We need to be able to do
something when something occurs,
be it a security event,
be it a misconfiguration event,
be it simply something
that needs to be cleaned up
because our policies and
constraints have changed.
So when we look at this,
how and where to federate,
how do we get our users authenticated,
really comes down a lot
to centralized federation.
I need to know who is who.
When it comes to encryption and privacy,
we really are looking
at a lot of automation,
and we'll talk more in
depth about each of these,
but I need to control my data.
When we talk about visibility,
visibility really is gonna
become centralizing that event
and log data,
because I need to see what's going on.
And team skills and tools.
This one is gonna be,
maybe a little bit of the
more complex conversation,
but I need to look into specialized tools
or specialized teams
because I need expert people.
I need expert resources
that can help me manage all of the above.
And so,
centralize federation,
as we talk about this
and we get into each of these
categories a little deeper.
This is a kind of a
single source of truth.
We'll talk about what those
sources can look like,
but essentially,
we need to be able to make sure
that all of our cloud providers
and our on-prem resources are going back
to a single source of truth.
Automation can mean monitoring
configuration, right?
Actively responding with
remediation around our data
and using cloud guardrails
and configuring them automatically.
Centralize data is,
eh, it's centralized logging.
It's pretty simple.
How we do that,
there's a lot of different
approaches, right?
And specialized teams and tools,
again, we'll get into this,
but essentially,
you might think about
specialized sub-teams
as part of your cloud
center of excellence,
or you might be looking at tools
to extend into the
different cloud providers
that you are operating with.
But let's start with identity
and access management.
- I think, technically,
we call this "Who's who."
- Yeah, yeah, the who's who.
- Who's who.
Okay, let's start with
identity and access management.
Again, the good news here is that,
we're tackling the challenge
that we already know
and understand, right?
Authentication. Who am I?
User system,
machine agent when it
comes to agentic AI, right?
Authorization. What am I allowed to do?
What are the permissions do I have?
And of course, accounting, right?
Tracking. What do I have access to?
What, in terms of data or
in term terms of resources,
do I have access to?
And I know a lot of you said
that you are already operating multicloud.
Who has already established a
centralized federation here?
A few of you.
This is one of the first things
we see some organizations do
when they go multicloud, right?
Because you want to have that
control in one single place.
And, probably, you're going to use things
like Microsoft Active
Directory, open-source LDAP,
Ping, Okta, something like that,
to give you that one source of truth
where you can control
your identity, right?
Where you have a better idea
of who's accessing your systems,
what those permissions
are to access the systems
and the data,
and keep track in case that
you have to investigate
or do some forensic analysis later.
So one of the first
challenges that comes up,
one of the first ones that
we see our customers tackle.
The recommended pattern
for these, in our opinion,
is going to be that single source of truth
for federated access for
multicloud resources.
So have that one place
where you manage all the identities
and all the access in
your multicloud state.
This is going to be enabled
by a third-party federation provider,
providing that identity source
that you need federation to work with.
So once you have this established,
it's going to give you two
very powerful benefits.
First one is that single point of identity
and access management, right?
Your team just to have
to focus on one place
to understand your estate,
who is who,
and what access they have.
And also,
it enables to maybe
put some higher controls and
standards in place, right?
For example, it might be
more palatable to users
to deploy things like
multifactor authentication
and complex passwords
because it's just one place
where they have to log on, right?
Your users are gonna be much happier.
They're gonna have one
place where they can log in
and they are not gonna have to log in
to disparate dashboards, disparate systems
to go through their day on operations.
So it's gonna be much easier for them.
And again, they might be more accepting
of tougher security controls
when it comes to users that
might be privileged, right?
Higher privileged users.
So really great benefits coming from this.
The tradeoffs are going
to be, in my opinion,
the first one is more of an investment
than a tradeoff, right?
You're going to have to
spend some time and effort
in the beginning.
Setting everything up is
going to be more complex
the more clouds you use,
and it's going to be exponential
if you have operating systems,
applications, portals, right?
It's going to create
that level of complexity.
It's gonna add up,
but it's gonna pay dividends
at the end of the day.
It's gonna save you time
from operational overhead,
managing all those different places
where your users may live.
And it's also gonna be a
lot easier for those users.
And the last three are
going to be related.
The reliance on a third
party is going to create
that dependency risk.
So you have to have really
tight break glass procedures,
so you can respond when
there's an outage, right?
So you're gonna have to be very clear
on how you are going to
operate if something breaks,
because there's that one place
where everybody's logging on
and where all the
administration's gonna happen.
So again, it's gonna be
a lot easier to sign on
and we're gonna be able
to avoid things like identity
sprawl, operational overhead.
So it's gonna be a lot easier
to establish your identity
and management once you centralize.
So now that you have an understanding
of who's logging onto your system,
let's see how to protect your data.
- So,
I think anybody that
is operating sort of on one cloud
probably starts to understand that
when data is all in one place,
it's a lot easier
and more straightforward
to control that data
because you can use
consistent guardrails and controls
within that cloud provider.
The challenge that becomes
in a multicloud environment is that,
that data begins to sprawl, right?
And we've got source code,
right, that has been deployed.
Maybe it's part of a workload,
maybe we're doing development
in virtual instances.
We have a ton of logs,
and those logs might contain
sensitive information,
they might have their
own data classification.
And we've got just simply data,
the data that our workloads work on.
And that can be anything from
PII, health... (stutters)
Yeah, yeah, there we go.
I was getting there.
And again,
what do we do about that data?
How do we understand it?
Well, we have policies that
are driving that, right?
So we have a data classification.
Whatever that works for you,
but you really should have
a data classification.
And if you don't,
you should go home
and really think about
having a data classification,
because that begins to define
things like data access.
Who can access that data?
Through what mechanisms
can they access it?
How is that data encrypted?
Do we need to apply a multilevel
approach to our encryption?
Is it just,
your kids' love letters
to their girlfriend
and we can just ROT13 that.
Who knows what ROT13 is?
Ooh, I'm dating myself.
Okay.
And what is the lifecycle look like?
Data gets left out
all the time, right?
We've seen a number of security events
over the years that have
occurred because data gets put
in a place without the
proper controls around it
and forgotten about,
only to be later discovered by someone
that we didn't want to discover it.
So this is why we need
to have these controls
classifications and access policies.
So how do we go about doing that?
Because it seems very daunting
to think about, you know,
you have development teams
ingesting data, producing data.
How do we get ahold of it?
The first place we want
to kind of start is
data security posture
management as an option.
Is anybody running a DSPM tooling now?
Okay, couple of people.
This is a very new space.
A number of really great
partner companies with AWS
have great product offerings around this.
They're here in the Village.
Make sure you go check them out
because data security posture
management can really give you
the tooling you need to go
understand how your data exists.
Right?
And that way, you can
start questioning like,
"Where do I need to go make changes?
Are my policies actually as
effective as they need to be?"
Things like that.
Cloud-native guardrails.
You should always question
what cloud providers offer you
in terms of protecting your data, right?
Obviously, I'd love to
tell you all about AWS',
from encryption to Macie and
tracking, finding your data,
and stuff like that.
But really, you should be
looking at those guardrails
and leveraging them where possible.
And then
questioning automation.
How can I pull automation in
to do things like monitoring
that data ingestion,
monitoring data migration,
monitoring how data is
being protected and managed?
Because then you can turn around
and assure compliance
for that data, right?
If you're under a compliance framework
that requires you to protect that data
because of its sensitive nature,
you're probably already
operating in this space
to assure that your data
is configured correctly.
And remediation.
If you go plug in something
like one of our DSPM partner tools,
you're probably gonna find a lot of stuff
that maybe needs remediation.
And the cool thing is,
when we talk about automation nowadays,
you know, even just a year or two ago,
I knew security teams that
would break out in cold sweats
when you told them that they
needed to write their own code
to do some of this automation.
But nowadays,
with agentic AI and vibe coding,
this is so much more approachable by teams
because this code can now get created by
literally anybody that can
write an effective prompt.
Find your prompt engineering
talk this week at re:Invent.
So what are the benefits out of this?
Well, DSPM is really streamlining
efforts in this space,
and that's great.
That means that it's one less thing
that security teams need to worry about
because tooling is emerging in this space
to really get a hold of
how your data is protected
and what controls are in place around it.
And automation adds efficiencies, right?
The story around automation
has always been the same.
Automation adds virtual
people to your team, right?
One of my past roles,
we were a very small
security team of like four
or five people operating on
thousands of AWS accounts.
So embracing automation is
really a very powerful thing
for any security team.
There's some challenges
around this though,
and you're gonna hear some
of these kind of repeatedly
through this talk.
Cost.
Right?
Tooling comes with a cost to purchase,
might come with a cost to
bring in professional services
from that tooling company
to help get the most out
of the tool the fastest.
So there's budgetary questions
that you kind of have to have.
While I just said
that creating automation
has gotten easier,
there is still a complexity to it.
Deploying it,
making sure that your
automation is reaching
all the places that it needs to,
all the nooks and crannies that,
you know, to discover data
and work on any type of
remediation, things like that,
especially as you become
more and more distributed.
And guardrails.
While the native cloud-native
guardrails may be great,
you should be evaluating them
against your security policies
to question if there's gaps.
And when there are gaps,
you should be looking at
one of these other options
to fill that in.
Making sure that you meet the objectives
of your security policies.
So, Luis tell us about
centralized logging.
- Or, what's going on?
(Geoff laughs)
So let's talk about visibility,
because you can't secure
what you can't see, right?
And this is one other topics
that sound really easy, right?
Just centralize your
visibility and you'll be fine.
But putting this in place is
more complex than it sounds.
Again, the complexity
adds up exponentially
because we're not just talking
about logs from one cloud
adding another cloud,
but each cloud is gonna
have a tech stack, right?
So you're gonna be adding logs
from your operating system,
from your database,
from your applications, right?
So it's an exponential level of logs
that you have to ingest, consume, analyze,
and add that to the data
protection mechanisms
that Geoff mentioned
that need to be in place
to protect those logs.
It starts to get
complicated really quickly.
Still, our recommendation
is to centralize those logs,
but we'll talk through some
of the considerations, right?
So at the high level,
centralizing those logs
will give you the
visibility you need, right?
So one place to see everything
in your multicloud
environment is the way to go.
This is going to be, again,
easier said than done,
but if you have that visibility,
you'll understand your
multicloud environment.
You can create a security baseline
throughout your multicloud environment,
throughout your estate.
You're going to be able to
derive themes and trends.
You're going to have alerts
and notifications that are
going to be from everywhere.
And it's going to give you
the ability to respond faster
to events,
understand what happened with
a lot more context and nuance.
So having that visibility
in one place, it's great,
but we have some tradeoffs, right?
And that's on the next
screen I'll show you.
So for the recommended pattern,
that's centralized logging.
For the enablement,
we have a security information
and event management system.
So this is another place
where, like we talked,
you may be able to expand the
tooling that you already have.
And if you already have expertise,
it may accelerate the implementation
in your multicloud environment.
Again, who here is already using a SIEM
for their incident
response and monitoring.
Yeah.
So if you have that in place,
you're already halfway there,
but of course,
you're gonna have to
take those considerations
when it comes to how to implement it.
So let's talk about the tradeoffs first,
and we'll talk about the
considerations after.
So the benefits that are gonna
be provided are real, right?
You're gonna have that central visibility.
That one place to see everything
that's going on in your environment.
It's gonna give you the ability
to understand your
environment a lot better.
You're gonna be able to differ normal
from maybe suspicious
or anomalous behavior.
It's going to give you all
the information you need
in one place.
And it's going to be able to
help correlate across clouds
for that faster response.
So if an event happens,
you can respond really quickly
and know if it's an incident,
and then try to do any
remediation you need to have.
Again, the first trade
off in my mind is going
to be an investment.
You're going multicloud anyway,
so a lot of this complexity is
gonna be audited by default.
And so if you spend some time
and effort in the front end,
understanding what logs you
need, where you need them,
what visibility you really need.
It's not gonna be about
collecting everything
all in the same place,
like in one database or in
one lake, or in one cloud.
It's about whatever your decision is
of where you put that data,
be it central or diversify
throughout your cloud estate,
having one place to get
all that visibility, right?
So that complexity,
that analysis that you're
going to do on the front end is
going to pay dividends
in the backend, right?
Because it's gonna be
a lot easier to respond
once an incident is happening,
and that's when time really counts.
So cost is a true consideration here
because of data and tooling, right?
Like Geoff said, tooling is
gonna be a cost consideration.
So you may have to start
thinking through use cases
that you need
so that you know what data
is ingested by your tool
and you are not incurring too much cost.
Data is also gonna be a
consideration when it comes to cost.
You're gonna make sure that
you're not duplicating data.
If you are moving data around,
cost may also be an issue, right?
Transferring that data
around may be costly.
So you have to consider that.
And you may wanna push
data through its lifecycle
so that you are putting data
in least costly storage systems,
so that you don't incur that
cost that you don't need.
Right?
Timing is going to be
an important thing here
because you want to respond
as quickly as you can.
So getting those logs
ingested, aggregated,
analyzed fairly quickly, almost real time,
so that you can react to them,
is gonna be very important.
And then, of course, time sync.
You may have different clouds
in different time zones,
so you may have different time
that you have to coordinate
and correlate before an incident happens,
because any times queue
during an investigation can
throw the entire time life up,
right?
So it's gonna make
the incident response a lot harder.
So those are a lot of the
considerations you have to have,
to have all that visibility in place.
Let's talk about the expertise
and tools that are gonna help you
once you have that visibility.
- Every time we went over that last slide
and we got to the challenge of timing,
you always told me it
was my horrible jokes.
(Luis laughs)
All right.
So expert teams and tools,
this is kind of an interesting one for me.
Again, I have some sort of
unique experience in this.
I came from a large company
prior to coming to AWS,
and
we we were large enough that
when we started to embrace
and expand into other cloud providers
for a number of reasons,
we were building sub-teams, right?
And the benefit of the sub-teams is that,
you're creating a team
of dedicated experts
around that cloud,
and then that team
becomes part of your
cloud center of excellence
that then is able to provide
security and architecture.
Security and architecture expertise voice
to your development
teams, to your leadership,
whoever needs that type of input.
And it also means that the management
of that cloud provider is
pushed down into the sub-team
who knows it best, right?
I'm also keenly aware
that not a lot of companies can scale
in this way, right?
This is typically more
like a large enterprise-type solution.
I think a lot of customers
are more commonly
on the other side of this slide,
which is the dedicated tooling,
where you have security teams,
you have maybe a cloud engineering team
as part of your CCoE.
And what you need is tooling
to augment that team,
tooling that can provide a lot of the
inspection, monitoring,
and the general wellbeing
of your architectures
and workloads in each cloud.
Because there are a lot of tools.
We encourage you to look for
ones that are cloud-neutral,
or maybe it's fair to just say,
tools that operate in the cloud
that you are trying to run workloads on.
'Cause you don't wanna run
down the path of one tool
for one cloud provider,
one tool for another,
because that doesn't
really fix the problem
in this particular challenge.
You should also look at the
tools that you already have.
Customers buy a lot of tools
that have features in them
that don't get used simply
because they don't necessarily...
They don't have workloads that need them.
There's a lot of tools
for configuration security
posture management, right?
CSPM or the new CNAPPs.
A lot of customers that buy
those for their AWS workload.
But that tool is,
also, a lot of those tools are ready to go
for Azure and GCP.
And so,
we should be looking at tools
that can just simply be
extended that we already have.
Question, whether or not
we should be buying a tool,
whether we should be developing a tool,
or simply looking into the
open-source community for tooling
that can achieve what we need.
And partners,
there's lots of partners out there
that have a lot of deep
experience in this,
that are ready to come and
partner with you and become,
effectively, that extension
to your team in this space.
So,
the enablement around this is,
one way or another,
your folks are gonna need some training
or you're gonna need to
hire additional folks.
Because if you're operating
in one cloud provider
and you suddenly start
operating in another,
you're not necessarily gonna have
even the most foundational
expertise in that other cloud.
So we're gonna have to train
and potentially hire to scale for that.
Partner tools exist.
There's a lot of them here
out on the Village floor.
We should definitely be talking to them
if this is a challenge
that you're up against.
Looking at, again, the
tools that you have,
and can they be extended?
Open source.
Open source is a place
where a lot of the tools
come out of the box,
ready to operate on a
number of cloud providers
because it's sort of the
nature of open source
that you don't want to
be locked in to a vendor.
You don't want to be,
you know, forced to do things one way.
And so the open-source community,
especially when you look
at a lot of the services
that are out there.
Terraform.
Terraform is really
into not being locked in
to one cloud provider.
They want to be able
to allow you to deploy
and manage architecture
on any cloud provider
that you're running on.
And cloud native services, right?
So there's a lot of cloud-native services
that might perfectly meet
or exceed your requirements.
And that's great.
You should always, again,
be evaluating it against
your security outcomes,
your security requirements,
and finding out like,
are there gaps?
Do we need to fill something in
through one of these other mechanisms?
And I think the benefits here,
the person scaling approach,
the sub-team scaling approach
has got a tremendous amount of benefit
in terms of specialized cloud expertise.
But is, again, that challenge
that we talked about,
it has whether or not
you are deploying tools
or you're bringing people in,
your cloud center of
excellence is going to benefit
from that
because you're gonna have
folks and tools attached to it
that are gonna be able to bring expertise
and additional controls
or monitoring to benefit
your development team.
And
the challenges.
I think the challenges are
probably pretty obvious
in this one.
So,
teams.
If you go the team route,
you can kind of get that
siloed effect, right?
Because
if Luis here is my AWS expert
and his team just does AWS,
and I'm the Azure expert
and my team just does Azure,
if something happens that we
need to withdraw workloads
from one of those cloud providers,
and we want one team or the other
to begin working on the other cloud,
that is gonna require training.
Their skills may become very siloed.
So it's just a challenge to consider.
It can be hard to find
that expertise natively.
So if you are looking
to hire people into your security realm
for it,
I think, most of us probably
in the security space are aware
that hiring security personnel
is difficult, at best,
right now.
But then to ask
for some very specific
expertise can become
really challenging.
Complex tool deployment.
Complexity kind of comes with the game
when we're talking about multicloud,
because now we have to deploy our tool
over a number of different cloud providers
and endpoints.
And obviously, management comes into play.
More tools, more people means
more resources required
to kind of keep them all
functioning smoothly.
Our manager deals with Luis
and I's petty arguments all the time.
- All the time.
- I'm just kidding.
Hey, so next steps.
So, next steps.
There's a lot of help available to you.
AWS has got a lot of folks internally
that are ready to come talk to you
about any of these challenges.
Your account team knows
how to find those folks,
folks like Luis and I
that are dedicated security specialists,
that have a lot of compliance
and architecture security experience.
And so if you're up against
one of these challenges,
talk to your account team,
pull in some of these resources.
We can definitely provide a lot of input.
- [Luis] We're gonna be
at the multicloud booth.
- Yes, and there's a multicloud booth
out on the Village floor.
We'll be there tomorrow,
but there's people there the whole time.
Definitely come have a talk to 'em.
It'll be security people,
operations people,
FinOps,
a number of different expertise.
We also talked about frameworks.
Again, this is really important.
You might or might not be
surprised the number of customers
that Luis and I talked to
who struggled to even define
their own security policies,
when great frameworks exist
to really help start
guiding you in this space.
So be sure to check these out.
I mean, these are very super common,
very well-known center
for internet security,
the NIST CSF like we talked about earlier.
Cloud Security Alliance has got a ton
of stuff available to you.
MITRE ATT&CK framework
is very cloud-agnostic.
So they really have got
a lot of good information
from a security perspective.
ISO.
ISO's got a ton of frameworks, 27k.
But even in the AI and AI security space,
which is emerging rapidly,
they have new frameworks
that have been published.
FedRAMP and FISMA.
If you're in that space,
you already know about 'em.
You pretty much can't operate without 'em.
And PCI.
PCI is a great one to look at,
even if you are not required
to be PCI compliant.
They publish a ton of stuff.
Lots and lots of auditors
and compliance folks know
how to operate around PCI,
and it provides a really good framework
for a lot of this security.
So, takeaways.
Security requirements don't change.
I don't care how awesome
the cloud provider
that your uncle runs is,
but you need to apply
your security policies.
You need to understand
your security outcomes
and you need to hold
true and fast to them,
and evaluate anywhere that
you're gonna run workloads
against those security policies.
- [Luis] Start cloud agnostic, right?
Start cloud neutral in high level
so that you can drive those
requirements throughout.
Remember to look at
outcomes, not implementation,
when it comes to the high level,
and then look at the implementation after.
- Look at extending your tools.
I mean most people,
most companies already own tools
that can be extended into
multiple cloud providers.
So if you're starting to think about this,
if you've started to move that way,
if you're trying to
rope in some shadow ops
that are going on in
other cloud providers,
a lot of people already have
tools that are easily deployed
to begin handling that.
- [Luis] And finally, data matters, right?
That data governance really matters.
Understanding where your data lives,
where it's transmitted,
where it's processed.
Geoff talked about data
protection and mechanisms,
automatic mechanisms to put in place
to understand where data is,
but also non-technical, right?
Talk to your people,
understand data flows,
understand what business
centers are using what data
so that you can understand
how to protect it more efficiently.
- And you might want to
capture these with your phone.
These are a couple of
really good resources
that you can explore from AWS' end.
The first one is the main
AWS multicloud landing page.
This has got a lot of really
great information links
to other resources within AWS
that can help guide a lot of this.
This page is rapidly growing with content
as we ourselves are beginning
to publish and develop helpful content
for customers in the multiclouds.
They're operating in multicloud space.
And the other one is the blog.
So just like we have a
number of other blogs,
like for instance,
the security blog that Luis
and I have published on.
Multicloud has a blog that is going,
that content is being
developed fairly quickly.
So definitely check it out.
And from Luis and I,
we super appreciate you
taking the time to be here
and listen to us,
and we'd love feedback.
So when you evaluate the session here,
please let us know what you think,
how we can develop this better for you.
And after this, we'll be right back there
and we're happy to talk to anybody
that wants to follow up on this.
So, thanks very much.
Enjoy the rest of your week.
(audience applauding)